i'm eight years old and it's my first
day at the new school
but i cannot express myself
actually i don't understand a single
word of english
my family just moved from korea to
england my mom is raising my little
sister and me and she's also finishing
her degree
she's nearly as lost as i am
but with the little english she knows
she speaks to my teachers in broken
english every day about how she can help
me at home
compared to many other parents in the
school who speak no english at all or
even scared to ask the questions she's
much better off and for that i'm much
better off
fast forward three months every time my
mom picks me up a swarm of korean
parents crowd round the car
it causes a traffic jam like every day
seriously
all the other korean parents gather
around the car asking my mom the same
questions that she asked my teachers
what is um parent-teacher conference
again
my kid is behind what can i do
i don't know how i would survive that
first year without my mom but i do know
that my experience is not that unique
every year 50 million children go
through the u.s school system
and out of that 40 million that is four
out of five children
come from underserved or immigrant
families we're talking about the vast
majority of the system here
i realize that i'm one of the lucky ones
because the law of averages will tell
you
that these children are likely to fall
behind by two whole school years
this costs the u.s economy almost one
trillion dollars every year
but it doesn't have to be that way
in fact research says that for a student
to do well a family's engagement is more
important than that family's wealth
a parent is a child's first teacher and
children spend eighty percent of their
waking hours outside the classroom so no
wonder
families are the game changer
so here's a trillion dollar question
how can we better tap into the
incredible potential of families and the
universal love for their children
this is why the organization i founded
helps teachers families and schools
connect
using something that we all have
a mobile phone teachers write the
communication in english and parents
receive it in their own languages
and vice versa
we break down the language barrier
bridge cultural and knowledge
differences by explaining education
concepts
and enable and prompt parents and
teachers to talk to each other
we're playing the role that my mom play
for the school and my friends families
the communicator the translator the
coach the explainer and the go-between
and since my mom cannot be everywhere
and in fact no parent can and that is
not for the lack of trying we've stepped
in and connected four million families
and students and educators in 70 000
schools today
when families and schools work together
everyone wins students are supported
families are empowered and teachers jobs
just become that much easier
the school environment and community
thrives with people from all backgrounds
even the system itself benefits
last year the u.s spent nearly 700
billion dollars on school-aged education
so imagine if you can increase the
return on that investment even just a
little bit
by connecting schools to engage with all
families
and we should it's literally a
no-brainer
but actually there's something much
bigger here than student grades
education goes beyond economic growth
and all goal goes beyond the classroom
schools are funneled to the real world
public education makes citizens
and in creating the next generation of
citizens we cannot be leaving behind
four out of five children or their
families
if we continue to pick and choose who
the system engages with generation after
generation like we do now
we will not be left with a community a
civil society or even a functioning
democracy
all collective well-being starts with
inclusive schools
and helping every child realize their
endless potential
so our hope is that one day
all underserved and immigrant children
and their families will feel that they
belong in the education system
our dream
is that one day
that they'll feel included in the very
communities that they're expected to
build
thank you
you